many high school graduations have
already come and gone but there was a
special one held today at Red Rock Lanes
8 news now reporter Candace Charles
stopped by to speak to some of the
graduates who say if it wasn't for this
local program they may not have lived to
get their diploma
the cure for the kids holds this event
every year but this year is even more
special as they have the largest High
School graduating class being emotional
just because you have kids graduating is
one thing but a year ago we I didn't
even know if he'd still be alive it's a
celebration for us it's a celebration
for them it's a celebration for their
parents because we never lost Hope For
The First Time In cure for the kids
foundation's history a record number of
current and cancer survivor patients are
graduating from high school 36 patients
celebrated at Bull for the kids we
really tried to take care of the patient
and the family as a whole Captain
sakovich is the director of patient
experience she tells me not only are
patients provided with medical and
dental care but also tutoring
scholarships and help with college
applications and it makes a huge
difference
[Music]
as Jordan Moreno continues to battle
cancer The Graduate tells me what
support from the cure for the kids he's
looking forward it feels good to
graduate I can't wait to explore the
future it's a big accomplishment the
doctor said I had about like 12 cans of
living Look at me now it's a chapter
that's closing but there's so much more
many of the graduates were diagnosed
with cancer as young children the
support from cure for the kids helped
them get to this moment they just know
they're not alone here for the kids
tells me they have about 300 Bowlers
here many of them are young patients and
that they help them get to their High
School graduation you can help the work
as well you can go by our website
8newsnow.com to find out more about cure
for the kids for now from Red Rock Lanes
I'm Candace Charles 8 news now now the
patients enjoyed a ceremony on the lanes
cap and tassel included the cure for
kids Foundation supports over 420
student patients and partners with CCSD
to operate on-site classrooms as
students undergo treatment